welcome fellow geeks enter the iphone 14
pro max in all of its deep purple glory
this is a beautiful phone and i can't
wait to game on this it runs an a16
bionic chip with six gigs of ram so
we're going to be running it on gadget
impact call of duty diablo mortal and
apex legends just a note we are shooting
this in 120 fps so you guys can see all
the frame rate drops as they come if
there are any you know i have no idea
what's going to happen once you play
those games and the other thing to note
is that this was played before the
release of ios 16 so a lot of these
games do not have support for io16 just
yet so we may be missing some features
from the settings but you know what
let's just see how it goes all right one
thing i forgot to mention is that we'll
be running geekbench on this as well so
let's just see how this fares all right
so let's check the base temperature on
the phone before we start anything
uh we're looking at about 27 ish
close to 28 but honestly it's a pretty
cool environment so
we're looking at about 27-ish 28-ish
around the top
honestly not so bad and the bottom here
is about 20
28 ish still but in higher regions
but you know what not to worry it's
still relatively cool to the touch
so let's just get into the games let's
just go into graphics real quick
highest let's go oh
balanced wow nice very nice
so let's just
check everything out high
high
highest
uh 60 fps
oh then only then it goes over clocked
oh that's interesting
okay and deleting on crowd density high
of course
and co-op teammates effects we won't
need to bother about that but yeah so
far it looks good everything's on the
highest
and let's go
of course the first place we want to
check out is monster that's where the
npc population is the most dense so
let's just tell you over there
[Music]
let's see how fast this is
all right pretty fast
[Applause]
okay let's just go
oh
wow
[Music]
already i've seen a couple frame drops
here and there
okay let's just ride in a straight line
and see
okay so far nothing much on this path
let's run back oh there we go a couple
more frame drops here
[Applause]
all right so now that we're done in
monster we're gonna head out to fight
some monsters in the wild
so let's just teleport somewhere
a little bit see where this gets us
thundering retribution
well let's just get into the abyss real
quick and see how this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
although i do suck quite a bit in this
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and that's pretty much it so
let's check the temperatures on the
phone real quick
[Music]
39 38
40 on this side
it is running pretty warm actually
[Music]
40 41.
right so combat wise nothing
noticeable no noticeable frame drops at
all except a monster for some reason
but other than that the iphone 14 pro
max handles it just fine so let's just
get into the next game
okay settings
graphics
okay let's go extreme hd let's go ultra
frame rate
and then get that smoothing why not
display fps yes
that's very helpful all games should
have that
high dynamic shadows on on on on on on
everything's turned on
and yeah we're good to go
let's just
jump in
let's go this way
oh this is really smooth
see even though i'm shifting my camera a
lot it's
it's not letting up
come on
come on come on
my
life
okay let's see how the finishes are like
oh it plays out a lot smoother than
other
kills i've tried
let's do a quick
mid game check
[Music]
oh nevermind
oh okay cool
so let's do a quick check
so on the front it's actually 5-ish
36-ish
nothing too crazy going on except for my
hamstring they're slowly pulling
oh 39 here oh okay wait firefight hold
on hold on
oh my god
though
let's push let's push let's push this
execution baby
[Music]
yeah let's just go to spitfire
never mind
recharging my shields
oh
[Music]
apex runs pretty well with the a16
bionic chip in there and it's i'm not
even not even kidding like it feels
really good to play on this thing it
looks really good on the screen as well
it's about 36 38 39 39.9 almost 40
degrees
around the bottom here okay so that's
where the chip is
all right
and then as we go down
it's not as bad
and it's not uncomfortable to hold it on
either ends honestly because like i mean
it does feel a little toasty like at
this exact spot but other than that you
know when you're playing it like this
you don't really notice it that much all
right let's check the back
yeah
yeah here
so
still not too bad
36 37 ish
it's healthy numbers healthy numbers i'd
say that real healthy numbers
so yeah
not bad apex not bad
so let's just
move on to the next game
alright and the next game is called duty
but i will say playing with the pro max
so far it's a lot more comfortable since
i have so much more real estate i mean i
i have huge hands
as i've said in the past but this thing
feels comfortable to play with
so the major looks good here
everything's pretty much fine let's go
check the settings real quick
in graphics and settings obviously the
little dynamic island thing does get in
the way a little bit so long as you can
tell what
is why i think i think that's fine so
let's go to the graphics
and just check out what we have for
multiplayer
let's set everything up here
to the highest and just turn everything
on and then down here
max and can we go ultra
oh we can't
you see yep
obviously you still can't do both at the
same time so just very high and max for
the graphic quality and the frame rate
so let's just
hop into a match and see
what's up
where am i
all right let's go
right now
oh
charlie
thank you
okay
uh wall machine don't worry look at them
any contact
is
there we go
all right frame rate is
pretty smooth i mean there's no
complaints here it's a pretty straight
game of
quality mobile without the gimmicks it's
real good
all right let's check the temperatures
real quick
and does it get higher at the bottom no
it does not oh sorry this is the bottom
here so the bottom is about 31 ish and
then as you go to the top it's about 32
almost 33 degrees
but you know what that's fine it's still
cool to the touch it's not like engine
where it's like 40 ish over
let's check the back
it's about 34 ish at the top
and then it just gets lower as we get to
the bottom
nothing much to complain here heat wise
it's great
frame rate-wise no complaints nothing
call of duty things are definitely yes
on the faulty pro max so
let's get straight into the next game
okay so
let's go here
to the settings and graphics and
yeah so
60fps not supported yet on the pro max
14
because we are playing this before the
launch of ios 16 and
you know a lot of these apps are still
not yet ready for io16 yet so give the
developer some time to let them update
the games so that you know we all can
enjoy ios 16 to its fullest and our
games to their full list
so let's just move on to ultra
resolution oh still can't do that hi
okay yeah sure we can do that
everything else is on very high so
yeah
let's get in
so let's run a challenge with real quick
i'm on number 13 right now um i hope i
can handle it i should be able to handle
it i think
so let's just solve this thing
so let's just push on and i'm going to
get my boots up yup yup oh my gosh okay
i'm kind of regretting this a little bit
already
even though i it looks like i'm steam
rolling there but honestly that's not
the case
statistically
see what i mean i am
i'm very scared right now
i don't think i can complete this riff
in time
but we shall see
yeah my damage output isn't as great but
you know as you can see it's handling it
pretty well at the tfps on the high
setting so far
okay with progress it's cool
all right
now's a good time
exterior
yes
get that get that get that at that let's
go let's go let's go let's go keep
pushing
so long as i have i keep up a constant
barrage
and command of skeletons
of spooky boys we should be good
yes it is
it's a fight let's go let's go look at
that crit it's crazy
you can do this we can do this okay come
on come on
yes
i just wish the crits landed
on the enemies that actually matter
so far can't find them yet
protection is what i need right now
oh yeah okay we got it you got it okay
let's get the roof out here real quick
come on come on come on come on
this handle sits
yeah okay we can win this we can win
this come on
yeah there we go
all right sick
i'm so hyped about this
yeah so as you can see even though it's
not at the
highest settings you know it's on 60fps
it does still look and feel very good
while you're playing the other immortals
so if you're going for any dungeon
around if you're gonna do any bounties
you know i'll just play the storyline
you guys will definitely enjoy
yourselves with the iphone 40 pro max
so let's do a temperature check on that
you know where the chip is at ish 35
degrees
not that bad actually
not that bad at all
yeah
oh
hell is definitely cold as hell
no
but yeah
honestly 35-ish 34-ish
not that bad
not that bad at all yeah it's
handling it pretty well no complaints
here right so for geekbench let's just
go straight into it
and run a benchmarking test so
let's do cpu benchmark
all right so the benchmark scores at 185
for the single core and 5520 for the
multicore so for all of you geeks out
there who love your numbers
this is pretty much how it'll run
so comparing to the previous 12 pro
maxes
it is a significant upgrade i'm trying
to find where the 13 pros are
and
wow i can't find any of that wow okay
cool
multi call let's see if we can find 13
nope nothing but you know
two generations apart
these are significant numbers so just to
show that we're not kidding with you
guys this is the 14 pro max and
surprisingly on geekbench it's
considered the iphone 15.3
not sure why but that's pretty cool i
guess
but yes for those who love their numbers
this is it
all in all it's very easy to say the 14
pro max does well okay not even that it
does extremely well at playing all these
games even though these games do not
support ios 16 just yet so
damn
if you guys are planning to get this you
guys will not be disappointed at all
also if you guys want more of these
kinds of videos we definitely have more
for you
[Music]
you